[inaudible]
joining me today as a writer and columnist that quill that magazine as well as a
philosophy major at Columbia University common use.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me on dude.
I had to change my shirt because your shirt looked so pressed and starched and
professional.
It's ironic because I normally dress like a complete slob.
I wear the same black hoodie every single day.
But I thought Ruben report you have to bring a game.
Let's do it.
I should've worn a tie,
but here we are.
Alright.
There's a lot of reasons that I want to talk to you.
Uh,
you were Sorta,
I think put on,
put on my map and put on sort of the IDW map and the map of all of the people
that care about the issues that we talk about here,
uh,
about,
what was it about five or six months ago,
something like that.
Something like that.
Your piece,
I want to get the exact title right,
was the high price of stale grievances.
And that was in [inaudible].
And you know,
I just had Claire on the show last week.
Uh,
so we're going to talk about a lot of things you've been writing about.
I want to talk a little bit about what it's like to be a student at a,
at a university these days,
especially on the,
that leans pretty far left and all sorts of stuff.
First,
just uh,
tell me a little bit about yourself,
where you're from,
how you grew up.
Well that,
that kind of stuff
from Montclair,
New Jersey,
uh,
which is just 30 minutes outside New York City.
Nice suburb.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I had a pretty typical middle upper middle class upbringing and a great parents.
Um,
and uh,
out of,
out of high school I was going to a music school actually I was dead set on
being a jazz musician and I still play drums,
Josh trombone.
Nice.
But along the line I ended up shifting paths and uh,
going into philosophy and enrolling at Columbia where I have two more years.
How do you go from jazz to philosophy?
There's probably some rely on merit.
I don't know that there is.
Honestly.
I think,
I think I just loved both of them and realized at a certain point that just
going to school for music was limiting.
Um,
so yeah.
Yeah.
So you said a middle class or upper middle class.
Did you have,
did your family have any particular political beliefs where you guys,
politico,
any of that?
My,
my mother was nearly a Marxist.
She,
um,
she,
I remember her talking to me about Marx and Durkheim when I was three and four
years old.
She,
she came from the South Bronx,
immigrant,
Puerto Rican family,
very,
very poor in the 70s when the South Bronx was the picture of crime and uh,
just decay.
And she,
she was very smart woman,
ended up getting a,
trying to get an anthropology degree,
but she passed away of cancer while she was getting it.
But no,
she,
I was,
I was exposed to two Marx and Durkheim and uh,
some other are other Marx's thinkers when I was,
I could have told you their names when I,
five years old.
Wow.
My Dad has a bit of a libertarian,
but I got less of his,
his,
he was working much at the time.
So yeah.
So that,
that's a real mixed household of the politics though.
Did you sort of lean one way or the other?
Yeah,
I always leaned heavily left if I,
if I leaned anywhere at all.
Yeah.
I mean as early,
Eh,
my,
the beginning of my political identity was definitely anchored around identity
politics and especially black identity politics.
Uh,
you know,
I was 24,
it was at 2013,
2014 when black lives matter started cropping up.
I was at that point very much enthusiastic about that movement I was posting on
Facebook.
I haven't seen a police shooting,
uh,
to the effect that this is,
this is proof that the system is rigged against black people so that that's more
or less what I was politically as of maybe five years ago.
So yeah,
that,
that was very much in my upbringing.
It was in the water,
uh,
in my,
in my social environment and intellectual environment growing up.
How much of that is part of the whole thing of just being around a certain set
of young people that believe a certain thing so that you all sort of believe it
together,
whether it's ultimately true or not.
Yeah,
I think,
I think we're social animals and,
and were heavily incentivized psychologically to not break ranks with the norms
of our social group.
So if,
if,
if those norms are that you have to believe in the god Vishnu,
Shiva,
than most people are going to grow up believing those things.
And it takes a kind of a rare personality to,
to be a contrarian in that context.
And if the norms are you have to believe in,
in,
and systemic racism,
you have to believe that America is a unique evil.
Uh,
then people will grow up believing those things.
And likewise,
if the norm is,
uh,
you know,
um,
abortion is murder and there is only one God and it's the Christian God and
homosexuality is a sin than most people in that context will,
it will end up believing those things.
So,
yeah,
I mean I,
my,
as far as my upbringing,
I think I can remember meeting precisely one Republican and he was my fifth
grade history teacher and he was such a good history teacher that,
you know,
in this public school that it kind of made up for the fact that he was a
republican because all the parents who want their kids to get ahead wanted them
in his class.
Right.
Yeah.
So you know,
it's something there,
there,
yeah.
Yes,
yes.
But I guess,
yeah,
long story short,
it was very much of an echo,
very much an echo chamber.
Very ideologically siloed.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so far your story I think sounds pretty consistent with a lot of what's going on
with,
with young people.
How old are you now?
2122 okay.
So you said in 2013 so only about five years ago.
He's,
you're 17
you're sort of in this thing,
this is the beginning of black lives matter.
When did you start realizing that perhaps it wasn't as much of a positive as it
had sort of been laid out to be?
Well,
I think it's hard to reconstruct one's own narrative after the fact.
But I remember one thing being significant,
which was when,
uh,
Michael Brown was killed in Ferguson.
I remember being in my first year of college taking,
taking a class at Julliard and we were talking about this killing and it was
just obvious from the point of view of most in the class,
including the professor,
that this was just another in a long line of examples of black men being
brutalized in a country that fundamentally does not want them to succeed,
to succeed.
And I don't know what like what it was.
It may have been because you know,
I had a roommate who was from,
from Arizona,
from a very different kind of political climate who was skeptical of this.
And I didn't even know how one could be skeptical of this.
It was so jarring to meet a person.
I liked that,
or many people I liked that were skeptical of the things I took for granted.
Yeah.
Were you guys able to get into it?
Because that's always one of the big problems here is that people can't do this
stuff with their friends anymore.
The thing is,
I think we were such good friends at that point for a political reasons that,
you know,
no,
no amount of politics was gonna was gonna destroy that.
But I think I just spent one night reading the complete testimony from,
from,
uh,
from Michael Brown's friend and from the police officer.
And I came away thinking,
well,
if the police officer's telling the truth,
then that was a justified shooting.
If his friend is telling the truth,
then it was unjustified.
But the,
I don't know who was telling the truth and no one in my class knew either,
but everyone had the same opinion so that,
I mean,
I remember that being significant.
I remember,
remember speaking up about that,
like when was the moment that you were kind of going,
all right,
I've got to say something about this.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure that I spoke up about it.
I'm not sure I would've had the confidence to speak up about it.
Yeah.
Were there a couple of other things after that cause I find it to be one of
these things that once you see this thing for what it is that then it sort of
happens very quickly.
I think a lot of people that watch this show,
I've acknowledged that because I think it's a lot of former former lefties or
whatever you want to call it,
that kind of see one moment like you just laid out and then they start looking
at other things and going,
wait a minute.
Maybe that's not how it is.
Maybe that person's not racist just because I disagree with them on this or
whatever the case may be.
I guess I can,
I can put the two other quick moments.
One was,
uh,
once I,
once I arrived at Columbia,
I heard of this Guy John mcwhorter,
who I,
I had no reason to believe anything about at the time,
but I just went,
I don't know,
a whim.
I went to the library and just search his name and pick the first book I could
find.
And it was called authentically black.
And it's a series of essays he wrote in the early two thousands about the fact
that it's viewed as authentically black to con constantly pointing the finger at
white people for any given problem in the black community.
Whether or not the evidence bears that out.
And,
uh,
because it's viewed as authentically black and there's this incredible taboo on
anyone who thinks differently.
And I was reading,
I was reading these essays and I remember thinking,
Oh my God,
this is,
this is right.
And I've never heard a black person say this out loud,
but it's,
it's obviously right.
And I didn't know you could say that.
I remember that that moment being significant,
but still the,
I mean,
these subjects are so hard to talk about.
I,
I do remember doing a,
at some point doing MTMA and this is where the most people have their break.
Yes.
Um,
I guess this maybe makes the,
the red pill analogy a little too literal.
There you go.
But I do remember,
I mean,
because you know,
I don't,
I don't enjoy being the black person at odds with most black people around me
are getting accused as I sometimes do of being self hating or an uncle Tom.
Like I don't enjoy that.
That's,
that's very much a cost of what I'm doing psychologically.
But I remembered,
remember doing Mtma and I was talking to a black friend of mine about race
issues and you know,
if you've ever done MTMA you know,
just puts you in this totally clear headspace where you love everyone around you
so much and you love yourself.
And I remember we were talking about race issues and I was articulating more of
the kind of points of view that I articulate now and it felt so silly that I had
ever had a hangup talking about these things in any other context.
And you know,
after that I just,
I felt like,
like there's no reason I can't try to approximate that more and more often.
Of course it's much harder when you're sober.
But the analogy though,
or the metaphor of the red pill,
it really has some value here.
How did that conversation end up?
I mean,
the Mtma laced conversation,
I feel like all,
all MTMA laced conversations go well.
Yeah.
I mean something has to be,
yeah,
it is.
I just,
yeah,
I think,
I think if we add more and more enter conversations with a mindset of the person
I'm talking to has reasons to believe what they believe in,
they're coming from a good place,
then a lot of conversations can go well.
That said,
I've had a lot of conversations with people since then that have gone extremely
well.
Sorry.
Extremely poorly.
Yeah.
And um,
have ended quite bitterly.
Yeah.
And I want to get to some of that and some of the things that people call you
and all that,
so,
okay.
So you have these,
you know,
a couple of successive moments of,
of waking up.
Um,
when did you finally start talking about this stuff?
You know,
I think,
um,
I,
I talked about it here and there with friends and family,
but,
and I had been trying to write about it a bit for the school newspaper and just
writing on my own,
but not publishing over the past year.
But I think what,
what,
what did it was when Kanye tweeted,
uh,
I liked the way,
I love the way Candace own thinks when he tweeted that something about that
moment was so inspiring to me to see someone who nobody on earth would question
their quote blackness.
Because in many ways Kanye is viewed as,
as the picture of blackness.
However one cashes out that term,
um,
to just to see him break ranks,
to see him break,
break the taboo,
even though he did it in a way that,
you know,
even though he's not an intellectual,
he said crazy things about slavery that,
that aren't true and endorse someone who I don't,
I don't see myself as having very much in common with namely,
namely Candice.
It just,
the fact that he was willing to break the taboo at all,
someone of his platform was so inspiring to me that that's when I started
writing for Colette.
Yeah.
So what was,
was this the first piece you put out for court?
I think that was the very first,
that was the very first piece.
Okay.
So the title of the piece,
as I said,
it was high price of steel.
Yeah.
This one was different.
This one was,
um,
uh,
this one was about Kanye and Candice.
This was right.
Right.
So this one got more traction.
The one that you're,
uh,
sorry.
Okay.
So I think this is so I don't think I was,
you are on my radar right from that one.
Although that probably that whole thing,
the whole kind of thing just sort of broke in such a crazy way though.
There were so many pieces written.
Um,
okay.
So let's back up then.
So then when you write this piece about Kanye in Kansas,
now,
you know,
Kansas is a friend of mine.
She's been on the show.
Uh,
I like her.
She has some tactics that are,
that are not my thing,
but that that's her thing and I can disagree with people and all that.
Um,
your basic feeling though,
this was a net good no matter what.
Um,
are there risks though in,
uh,
you know,
taking somebody like a Kanye and having that be the moment that wakes up people
because you don't know where he's ever going to go with things where it's just
the action itself.
Enough
I get,
I guess time will tell.
I think it is inconvenient that Kanye,
I love his music and,
and I've been a fan for a long time,
but he clearly has some narcissistic element to his personality.
He,
he's clearly not someone who deeply researches the subjects that,
that he sometimes talks about.
So he kind of took a very blunt sledge hammer to a taboo,
which I appreciated.
But there are,
there are serious downsides to that.
Namely when he says that slavery was slavery was a choice.
Something that ignorant seems to discredit his taking the sledge hammer to the
taboo when I do think they're separable in principal.
I also think
when he said,
you're talking about when he said that on TMZ,
right?
Yes.
And his counter argument to that was that he means that it's,
it was sort of a mindset.
Yeah.
I think was his counter.
Right.
Yeah.
So it just,
that that sound byte reads so awfully because it seems so uninformed regardless
of what his,
his intent was there that it can,
it can seem to discredit that he did a good thing on the net on net balance.
Yeah.
And yeah,
I also,
I,
you know,
I have,
I have reservations about cat cat as owners as well.
I've,
I've seen her a reason in ways that I think don't make much sense,
although I have some points of agreement with her too.
But like I said,
I think I,
I think there is a taboo that is incredibly strong right there.
There are lots of black people who agree with some version of,
of my takes on race and are absolutely mortified to say so because there's this
massive taboo.
Yeah.
And that's also why for again,
whatever my disagreements are with Candace,
it's like I see her as someone that's trying so desperately to break something.
The very thing that you're talking about.
So it's like if she's using tactics that maybe I wouldn't use or you know,
tweets in a,
in a more hostile way at people or whatever that I would do.
It's like I don't know that I am the one that shouldn't be telling you how to
behave in that regard.
Yeah.
Does that make sense to you?
Not so much.
Only because I feel like there are a lot of people who might like what Candice
says on race.
For example,
someone Candace says,
you know,
to go,
it goes to a college and says,
[inaudible] sees all of all of these black students reminding her of the history
of Jim Crow,
which they didn't even experience and using that as,
as as a rhetorical weapon.
And Candice says,
listen,
you were born in 1990 right,
I completely agree with that.
That is,
that is a message that needs to be hammered home,
which is that histories in the past.
And we have to be getting past history.
But you know,
when she says that you're on the democratic plantation,
I think that is a kind of exaggeration that is not useful because people with a
different set of intellectual priors,
we'll just hear that and be immediately closed off to,
to whatever else she says.
And you know,
I've also heard her just reason in ways on Joe Rogan for example,
when he pressed her on climate change,
you kind of appealing to a sort of feeling over facts kind of way of thinking,
which is actually quite characteristic of far left.
But yeah,
she,
I think she also gets treated unfairly and she gets assumed to be a sellout.
Um,
which I think is,
is,
is ridiculous,
ridiculous assumption to make about people in general unless they make it
absolutely clear that they are.
So I'd be,
you know,
she's,
she's someone I would be happy to talk to at some point,
but
I'm happy to set that up if you'd like to make it happen.
Okay.
So you write this piece.
Now this is the first public piece that you've written about this stuff.
Did you have any idea what kind of reaction you were in store for?
No.
Walk me through that moment.
Um,
yeah,
I think it got retweeted by Christina Hoff Summers and Jordan Peterson and Sam
Harris and some other people and it really,
really blew up.
And uh,
yeah,
I that was psychologically distressing because,
you know,
I'm a normal person,
so when I go from having 50 Twitter followers to 10,000 and yeah,
in a week or something like that,
that is a pretty life deranging moment.
And uh,
it was,
it was just kind of physical stress,
a low level physical stress all day and not sleeping as much,
but you,
you get,
I think you get,
you'd be surprised what you can get used to.
Um,
so
we were,
you shocked were you were getting defense from and where are you were getting
outrage from or I assume you expected it at least at some level.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think I was shocked by that.
I mean,
I knew at this point I knew at this point exactly who would be very pissed off
by,
by my,
my opinions.
And at this point I had resigned myself to,
to be to those people being pissed off at me.
And No,
I'm not,
I mean,
I'm not surprised that they're quote IDW types,
uh,
liked my work because I like a lot of their work.
Um,
so no,
I guess that wasn't,
that wasn't so surprising.
Yeah.
So when you then wrote the piece,
the high price of state,
the high price of steel grievances,
which was also in quilt that you started with a quote from felonious monk that I
thought was sort of worth diving into here,
they tried to get me to hate white people,
but someone would always come along and spoil it.
There's something about that quote that strikes me as so relevant to what's
going on right now that we are not looking at people as individuals and that
every time you do,
you will be pleasantly surprised because most people are not walking around in
this state of hate.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think it's striking.
I mean,
I,
and I,
um,
juxtapose that quote with another from the New York Times,
from a New York Times op Ed published last year,
uh,
which argued that black children should be taught to fear white children based
on the history of racism in this country.
Uh,
and the quote was,
as against our gauzy national hopes,
I will teach my boys,
my black boys to have profound doubts that friendship with white people as
possible.
Right?
So that got published in The New York Times in 2017.
Uh,
you know,
Sarah Jon got hired,
uh,
having,
having written incredibly nasty tweets about white people in 2018 by the New
York Times,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's disturbing to me that you can't,
you can't really find at this point on the left,
even on the mainstream left,
just the simple articulation that a person's race does not matter to their moral
worthiness to their intellectual worthiness.
It is,
it is an irrelevant character.
You can't find the language of,
of,
of appeals to colorblind humanity virtually anywhere on the left at this point.
Um,
that,
that is disturbing to me.
How shocking is it to you?
Because I think people are still kind of shocked,
you know,
I've been banging this drum for quite some time and I think I see people waking
up to it now and I'm like,
man,
how didn't you see this?
You know,
these,
these last couple of years because it's so obvious to me that we've gotten here.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it is shy.
Me,
I,
I do remember growing up,
you know,
in the,
in the public school system,
in my town we would have Martin Luther King Day assemblies is very diverse town,
maybe 25 30% black and 60% white.
And we would,
we would get the,
you know,
the,
I have a dream speech style ethic around what it means to be a human and how
important or unimportant one skin color is.
And it seemed like such a,
it seems like there's such a good argument to me and it is the best argument
with regard to people's,
you know,
the,
the assumed,
I guess
w w w what I mean to say here is that I've been in spaces at Columbia for
example,
or conversations where my being black,
it was obvious to me that there was an assumption of,
of moral worthiness or have a kind of heightened moral knowledge that I would
have as a black person that a white person wouldn't have.
And you know,
I think,
I'm not the first to make this analogy of course,
but the real religious analogy and the analogy to original sin is pretty apt.
Um,
because it,
I mean the,
the way though,
this has a lot to do with black history also because the way I,
the way I see it,
they're kind of two ways to study history.
There's the conventional way,
which is,
you know,
you study World War One,
you study the causes and consequences read different takes on,
on,
on the significance.
And once you've studied,
all you need to know,
you move on to the next topic.
But then there's a religious way of studying history,
which is,
it's not enough to know the facts.
We have to go somewhere on Sunday,
every,
you know,
every single week and learn,
talk about same stories over and over again.
So this is,
you know,
it's,
it's the difference between how an atheist learns about the life of Jesus and
how a Christian learns about the life of Jesus Jesus and relearn it every week
for the rest of their life.
In my view,
how we're looking at the history of race relations in this country,
the history of racism,
we are more and more putting it in the religious category of history where,
you know,
I can read a piece about the history of lynching in the New York Times almost
once every two or three months.
Right.
And let me,
lynching is a decades old crime at this point.
And Avi,
I mean,
Jesus,
Great.
Obviously it was a,
a heinous staying on,
on this country's legacy,
you know?
But then the number of deaths that that is is the highest amount quoted in New
York Times with regard to how many black people were lynched in this country is
around 4,000,
right.
Every single year.
Twice that many black people die of homicide.
And I,
you just don't even hear about that in the New York Times.
So what do you make of the fact then?
So this is something that like a Sean Hannity,
he'll talk about,
he'll,
he'll say that exact thing and now if you say,
and then people will say that somehow that makes him racist cause he's focusing
on black on black crime or something like that.
So how do we have that conversation then?
Because I think partly what's happening is the outreach,
you know,
someone mentions it,
he happens to be someone obviously on the right.
Uh,
I don't know what his intentions are.
I don't know the guy,
but he's,
he's at least talking about it.
What you just said,
people aren't talking about it.
Yes.
But then pays a heavy price to talk about it.
That then has the chill effect that it's like people are like,
all right,
I'm not going to talk about it.
So we can look at the crime statistics in Chicago every week and you should care
about these statistics where there's people are white or black or whatever,
but people are just like,
I don't want to touch it because I don't want these labels.
Yeah,
it is,
it is decidedly.
I mean this is one of the reasons why,
you know,
I'm,
I don't see myself as a natural ally to a canvas Owens for example,
because there are so many other things that she says that,
uh,
you know,
that,
that I don't agree with.
And I guess it's the Sean Hannity problem too because if you can't criticize a
Sean Hannity or Candice Owens for all of the things that,
that they're saying that are unjustified by the evidence,
it's Candice Kaye Candice's case.
It might be climate change or,
or whatever it is,
um,
for Sean Hannity could,
could be other things.
Then I guess you just have to be able to make these subtle distinctions.
But at the end of the day,
homicide is the leading cause of death for young black men aged 15 to 34
according to the CDC.
It is not the leading cause of homicide for any other race or,
or age group.
Um,
can we talk about that?
I mean,
is it the case that we're where we're so close to white people turning the hoses
on us again
to the Sean Hannity is and,
and they're supposedly deplorable.
Um,
yeah.
Followers that that were just so the threat of white supremacy is so ever
present of resurgent white supremacy that we can't talk about the leading cause
of death among young black men,
that,
that that is not sustainable.
Amy,
the,
the fundamental problem I see with how the left in general thinks about race is
that the concerns about race and racism are totally unattached to the degree to
which black people are suffering on any given issue.
Right?
So we're talking about the leading cause of death for young black men.
And I never read about this in the New York Times and I,
and I know that I won't,
right?
So this is,
this is a problem that is central.
It is.
It is bigger than the problem with police violence.
It is bigger than you know.
Then the problem of microaggressions,
it is bigger than the problems of of systemic bias and yet there is,
there's virtually no concern for this on the left because the,
the,
the way I see many progressives think about race issues is a perpetrator side
concern,
which is if the perpetrators of the problem are white,
that it's worth talking about.
If the perpetrators of the problem happened to be black and it's not,
we're talking about,
the problem with that is that it's untethered to any concern for the level of
suffering on this side,
on the victim side.
Do you think it's a fair estimation to see this is the new racism in a weird
way,
like it's,
it's almost uncomfortable to say it,
but I had a,
an educator in the UK here in the summer,
Katherine verbal sing and that's basically what she said,
that these people are now the racists,
that the racist ideas of the day are actually coming out of the left now.
I don't want to use the same tactics.
Right.
I don't want to sit here and be like,
they're all racist and blah,
blah,
because we know that that doesn't really get us anywhere.
Yeah.
The general idea of that,
do you think that that's a fair way to frame [inaudible]
things?
I wouldn't frame it.
I mean,
the way I would frame it is that there is a kind of racism on the left and it's
the kind of racism where the New York Times higher hires a writer who says that,
who celebrates the idea that white people stopped breeding.
Right.
And doesn't apologize for it.
Yeah.
No concern with how that,
how that's going to translate to no white people in this country who have vastly
less privileged than the,
you know,
the tech writer at the New York Times.
And what about that statement that they issued defending her?
Yeah,
you saw that where it said something about the hate she gets as a young Asian
woman and it's like
what?
That that's now a new thing that you can,
that you get to be racist because gotten trolled online.
Well,
you know,
I mean that,
so coming back to the question that is that that is,
I'm happy to call that a kind of racism for sure.
It's the only reason I would say there I wouldn't go as far as to say they are
the new racist is because there are still racist on the other side and I fully
expect there to always be some amount of racist in society and some amount of
racist incidents like the way this is another problem with the way many on the
left think about race is that they,
they tend to view the problem of racism.
Kind of like we view the problem with smallpox,
which is to say something that can be fully eradicated down to the very last
person who has it.
And then we can put a date on the time when smallpox is no longer a problem
forever.
Whereas I,
and I would argue anyone who's really thinking rationally about this problem
should view racism as more,
more like a problem like murder,
right?
Like the murder rate in New York City's to be 10 times higher than it was today.
Just 20 years ago it was,
it was absolute carnage.
So the,
the rate is,
it's come down tenfold.
New York is notoriously safe at this point is something like 200 murders,
two or 300 murders last year.
Right.
What would it take to get the murder rate down to zero to the point where there
was not a single murder in New York City,
you'd probably have a murder everybody.
Yes.
You have to get,
I mean you have to embrace a totally totalitarian vibe from the top down.
It could be done,
but it would not be worth what it took to get there.
You'd hit diminishing returns.
So I view the problem of reducing racism,
reducing racist incidents against black people as a problem,
like homicide rather than smallpox,
which is to say you can certainly reduce it and we have massively,
but there was a point at which in a country of 350 million,
there will always be enough people who are racist to,
to justify a certain amount of racist incidents and to fight it beyond that,
endlessly you hit diminishing returns.
Yeah.
And also that it's depressing and it kind of sucks,
but people can be racist.
Like privately,
you can be racist now.
You can't discriminate against people and there's all sorts of reasons that you
can't bring that into public life,
but in your own mind,
in your own home,
you can be,
I would prefer people not be,
but that they're trying to eradicate like something that's actually just part of
the mind.
Yeah.
You want to,
you want to educate people enough so that they hopefully won't hold those views,
but that is the diminishing returns because you're literally going to be in
people's houses at that,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a question of not.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess there's a question of what your view of human nature is.
This comes down to very fundamental pillars of one's a political ideology,
which is do you have a kind of Utopian view of human nature where there's
nothing tragic about us,
nothing flawed about us,
and all of the flaws come from bad ideas in the culture and humans are naturally
poised to be just perfectly selfless until we get ruined by society.
They see that,
that I think there's no reason to believe that at this point,
right?
Like chimpanzees and murder and like there were animals in the animal kingdom.
It's not to say that where our human nature is fundamentally evil either it's,
it's clearly there's a,
there's a wide range of potential there,
but there's no,
no reason to assume that we're evolved to be not racists or that were evolved to
be,
um,
you know,
woke perfectly woke or that it's possible to get to a point where everyone in
society has been fully purged of every ounce of evil in their heart.
I mean,
that is such a utopian outlook.
And like I said,
the,
to the extent that you're fixated on that goal,
to the exclusion of the costs of your fixation,
you,
once you hit diminishing returns,
you will be fighting a fight that is a net bad for society.
All right,
let's talk about systemic racism or at least the idea of systemic racism.
So I think you've seen the video of me about two or two and a half years ago
with Larry elder and I brought up systemic racism.
Larry elder proceeded to commit a hate crime on me,
a white man.
He beat me senseless with statistics.
Yeah.
And I came to a fight not ready to fight basically.
And that was definitely one of my red pill moments,
so to speak.
I was not prepared.
I heard new information.
I did research after that.
Subsequently,
I've had many people on this show and many conversations,
uh,
that have led me to more of Larry's original premise.
Um,
so I guess first when you,
when you saw that moment,
uh,
was that the first time you'd ever seen me do anything?
Cause that's what a lot of people telling me.
And I'm like,
oh,
I don't think it was the first time.
But I think,
I mean I don't envy anyone who is debating Larry elder on anything.
He's,
he's pretty devastating.
It must have been kind of refreshing though when you saw this moment where he
laid it out and you know there was no counter cause there is no counter.
Right,
right.
Well yeah,
he,
what he did with you there is he,
he went through each specific venue in which supposedly there is this big
systemic racism problem where the system is rigged in such a way that it doesn't
require any individual in the system to be racist in order for the system to
spit out racist outcomes.
That's essentially the idea of systemic racism.
So he went,
he went with you through,
he said,
just name,
name a place in society where you think systemic racism exists and he just di Ba
ba basically destroyed each one with the specifics of,
of the case.
And I'm not going to do a better job than he did there and he's capable of
doing.
But there's a bigger picture way to test this systemic racism hypothesis,
which is to take two populations where it's,
it's a very messy crude science experiment.
But to take two populations where you're holding systemic racism,
constant,
namely black Americans like myself and black immigrants,
especially black immigrants from the West indies and their children.
They're talking about immigrants from Jamaica,
Barbados,
other places in the West indies and specifically their children.
They're American born children.
So these are people you could not tell apart from black.
Like you couldn't tell if I didn't tell you that I wasn't the child of a
Jamaican immigrant or something.
Right.
And you find the,
the thing about these is that these two populations differ in many ways.
Some,
some,
some ways are very hard to quantify,
but they differ culturally.
They differ for all kinds of reasons.
Um,
because partially because the kind of immigrant who gets out of a Jamaica
differs systematically is going to be disproportionately intelligent,
disproportionately hardworking,
whatever the traits are that get you from Jamaica to New York,
say that's a cluster of attributes that that makes that population differ.
But there's,
there's one thing that is not different,
which is they're subjected to whatever level of systemic racism exists.
So Thomas Soul has done good work on it.
Back in the 70s,
he showed that,
uh,
second generation west Indian west Indians living in the same city as black
Americans were earning 58% more,
right?
So they're,
they're both being treated to whatever degree badly by white people there.
Whatever this,
whatever system you want to suppose is holding people back is equally affecting
both of them.
Uh,
the Columbia sociologist van Tran has a great essay in which,
uh,
um,
this,
this difference is brought out.
You find neighborhoods of,
of black Americans right next to neighborhoods of black west Indians in New
York.
They're equally segregated from white people.
So it gets rid of,
you know,
this,
the,
the idea that being segregated by seller,
living around people who only look like you is inherently a,
um,
uh,
a disadvantage.
Um,
it gets around the policing issue because these populations are being police.
The police can't tell the difference between a second generation west Indian
and,
and a black person.
It gets around whatever level of systemic racism is or isn't in,
in the pipeline with regard to schools.
And you find wildly different outcomes.
You find,
you know,
rate of high school graduation,
much higher for black west Indians of rate of enrollment in college,
much higher.
We may rate of professional occupations much higher crime,
lower,
right.
So this suggests to me that there are,
that the role of systemic racism tool to whatever degree it exists is,
is minimal at this point.
Uh,
and the,
the,
there's a whole narrative built around the idea that this is the primary
obstacle facing black people.
And it's worth noting.
I don't,
I don't think most black people actually believe this because I mean there,
there are various poles to site here,
but there's,
there's one from Pew that,
that asked black people without high,
without college educations has,
has raised.
How has your race held you back at all in life?
60% said no.
That's a recent pew poll.
Another Gallup poll asked his bias,
the main issue facing you in,
in,
in jobs and housing.
60% again said no.
The,
uh,
the Harvard sociologist,
Ethan Foss has done extensive polling of the black community and found that
disconnected black youth,
which are black youth without who aren't in schools and don't have a jobs.
The people on the lowest rung of society,
something,
something around 30% of them think the system is rigged and 70% don't.
So what,
what we're getting is we're getting the voices of black people who believe the
systemic racism narrative promoted to the,
to the most powerful,
uh,
media positions in our country.
So we're getting the impression that this is a uniform view and it's not.
Right.
So this is sort of the Jesse Jackson's Al Sharp.
They get moved up because they're given sort of simple answers.
So I guess it,
it Harkins the question then I can ask this either way.
What is it that the west Indian immigrants are doing right?
Or what is it that the other folks are doing wrong?
Yeah,
I mean you can answer that in either direction.
Sure.
Well,
partly,
I mean,
part of it is just immigration selection factors that I mentioned,
right?
So the,
the kind of Jamaican or Barbadian who makes it off the island to New York did
likely to be disproportionately hardworking,
disproportional,
disproportionately x for whatever x factor is.
And so in that sense,
the direct comparison can be misleading,
but it just analyzing why these two populations differ.
You Find West Indian immigrants,
uh,
more likely to come from a two parent home.
Um,
you know,
more likely to have,
have had a more classically socially conservative upbringing,
which is,
you know,
you don't talk back to your parents.
Parents are rather strict.
There are downsides of course,
to that style of parenting.
But,
um,
it basically what I'm saying is that there are cultural factors that are
important that differ between these two groups.
Right?
And you find if there,
there,
there are many,
I mean this is,
this is where the conversation for many people get to especially uncomfortable,
right?
It's the idea that every culture,
every subculture is identical in the behave behavioral patterns that are
inculcated and wherever there is some were,
wherever there is a disparity in some outcome,
it's not possible that culture accounts for some or most of,
of that disparity,
which I think is very silly idea.
Well,
it's completely nonsensical.
Yeah.
Cultures are different.
Different people in different groups put different emphasis on certain things.
So I'm a little more on families and but more on education,
so,
but more on sports or whatever the hell,
whatever the hell it is.
So when you hear Larry elder make the argument,
you know,
something around until 1972,
the black family had a higher rate of,
of staying in marriages.
And then he lays out the reasons that he believes policies of the Democrats
destroyed,
all that.
That,
that obviously resonates with you,
right?
Because you're,
you're giving me some piece of this,
both answers I think resonate or went back to family rates of marriage and some
sort of conservative ideals.
Well,
yeah,
I mean that's a very complex,
people hate when you talk with,
when anyone talks about this about family,
people just absolutely hate it.
It is the fact
that black,
the,
the rate of two parent homes and marriages was pretty similar to the white rate
until the 60s.
Um,
it is,
it is a,
it's a matter of scholarly dispute as to what was the cause it,
I think it's certain at this point there was no one,
cause welfare state may have had something to do with it,
but I think it may have just been changing norms in the culture.
What?
Cause we're seeing the same thing happen in,
in,
in the white working class as well now with the decline of,
of two parent homes to a lesser extent than,
than has happened in the black community.
Um,
yeah.
So,
so I guess what,
yeah,
so I mean we could talk about some of the,
the most important behavioral patterns that are different between a black
families and white families and Asian families.
Um,
I mean there,
there are some statistics that I,
I just,
I don't see any way in which this could possibly be explained by systemic
racism.
For example.
One is that if you ask 13 year olds if they've had their first sexual experience
yet,
you get 9% of of white saying yes,
you get 21% of black people saying yes.
Right?
So it's more than a two fold difference there.
And that has everything to do with family dynamics with,
with there not being two parents in the home.
It is a development issue more than it is an issue of treatment by white people.
Right.
I have another piece in Colette,
uh,
called black American culture and the racial wealth gap where I talk about
spending differences and you,
you,
you know,
Nielsen,
the marketing firm has done,
done research on this,
found that the average black woman is more likely to own a luxury vehicle than
the average white woman,
despite the fact that the average black family has one 10th,
the wealth of,
of,
of the average average white family spending patterns on,
on jewelry and expensive clothes are very different in the black community.
Um,
whatever you want to say about these from an ethical a,
this is not,
I mean,
I'm not good enough.
Want to make an ethical judgment is,
I mean,
I'm not finger wagging at people saying do x,
don't do y.
I'm saying
there are,
there are entire books written by respected left wing scholars about issues
like,
you know,
wealth or income or that just don't mention a single one of these facts as if
it's not relevant.
Right.
So what's,
what's the through line then or the connection between all of this and the
welfare state?
Because the more that I've explored these ideas,
the more that I am starting to buy that.
That almost is the,
the real problem here that we've given a certain amount and then it's just human
nature.
People don't want to stop being on the Dole.
That has nothing to do with race.
You could give it to anyone,
but in this case we happened to be talking about black Americans,
but I can give you just one simple example,
which is my sister lives in a,
in Manhattan,
not that far from you actually,
and she's in a building that's part subsidized.
So there's a lot of black people in the building that had been there for
generations now that are,
they're subsidized.
My sister and her husband,
two kids,
they're not rolling in dough.
They're paying full market price,
but the people that are in the subsidized housing,
it's almost impossible for them to leave.
I don't even blame them because they're paying next to nothing.
And if they wanted to work more,
they'd probably,
and then get off the subsidies.
The subsidies,
they probably have to leave the building in the first place and go live
somewhere worse.
So we end up with this horrific catch 22 that again,
I don't believe,
I don't put this on race.
It just seems to be affecting people of a certain race more.
Yes.
I think,
I mean,
I think it's clear that there was a point in,
in,
in the late sixties and seventies where the welfare state was clearly
incentivizing counterproductive behavior disproportionately among black people.
Um,
I mean,
the reason I yeah,
I,
I don't,
I think we need a welfare state.
I think there's,
there's really no free market.
There's no capitalist economy in the world that doesn't have one because they're
just,
and you know,
people's jobs are being taken by automation and that's only going in one
direction.
And we clearly need a welfare state and we need one that doesn't incentivize,
uh,
you know,
counterproductive behavior.
And we haven't always had that.
And Yeah,
when you say [inaudible],
you mean some sort of social safety net?
That's what I'm heard.
Yes,
correct.
Because I think people would you say welfare state,
I think people have a different sort of,
kind of
perhaps.
Yeah.
I mean it's social.
I mean something that catches the people who can't really can't help themselves,
who can't trade their skills for money in the market.
Yeah.
I'm with you.
So,
so then how do we untether the issue of people that are now stuck in that
machine where every time you talk about it,
you're called a racist?
No,
I mean this is,
yeah,
it is extremely pernicious because I think it's clear that the welfare state,
the way it was rolled out in the sixties and seventies had bad effects for black
people.
Right?
It's,
it's,
it's hard to fully explain the decline in two parent homes without noticing
that,
you know,
a black mother in the early seventies stood to lose money by getting married to
a guy.
Right.
Because of the perverse incentives of the welfare state.
That said,
it's not just because the welfare state was one of the causes of the decline of
the black family doesn't imply that taking it away would repair it.
So I think,
I think that is something like Charles Murray,
for example,
the big book in the 80s that made him big losing ground,
which criticized the welfare state very much along these grounds,
but I think even he has acknowledged that at this point,
removing it once you've set it all into motion,
it's not obvious that removing it is a cure,
which is,
which is tragic,
but
true.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a real tragedy because then it's like,
I mean,
this is where you would definitely have a difference of opinion with Candice
worked.
Her argument is rip the Bandaid,
rip the Bandaid,
let the pieces fall where they may,
I don't know what her policy is on that and helping the poorest of the poor or
whatever.
Like are you literally going to be kicking people out of their houses?
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but I think there's,
there's a growing feeling I think at least of a certain set of people that it's
not working.
You're acknowledging why it's not working and these little bandaid fixes
seemingly only make it worse.
Yeah.
It's,
I think it's a very complex issue
because there are,
there are some,
there are some elements of the social safety net that I think economists agree
are working.
Like the earned income tax credit,
which actually incentivizes you to work.
It helps the worst off people in society without,
it basically corrects the massive mistake of welfare in the Lyndon Johnson era.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a complex issue.
Yeah,
sure.
So I hate to talk about race this whole time.
It's like kind of annoying.
I know it's what you mostly write about.
What else is kind of on your mind,
like what are the other issues that you care about?
I mean,
we can keep going on that,
but I always feel like it's like,
it's,
that's also a sort of tragedy of all of this.
It's like your whole world view is to move past all this and yet because of that
you get thrust into the conversation.
It's a weird,
a weird psychological condition,
I suppose.
Yes,
it is.
Does that just drive you crazy in general?
Yeah.
I mean I don't,
before we move on,
I am racist.
I find inherently interesting.
Yeah.
I think it is like when I have,
when I have a free moment to,
to read a book,
I'm not ordering the race book because,
but,
but at the same time,
it is a topic that's loomed so large in our politics.
And so much of what is said makes so little sense that I,
it,
it just gets to me.
So I have to say something,
but it's not something I enjoy.
I mean what,
what I really enjoy is a philosophy and science.
Um,
so,
so when I have free moments,
I,
I tend to read things in those,
in those Janrus.
Yeah.
While you're working for the right lady,
Claire over there collect cause that that's what she cares about too.
So actually we can shift a little bit.
So,
uh,
you attended an event,
that,
uh,
there's an IDW group in New York put together.
I was put together in like two or three days.
It was me and Eric Weinstein and Faisal Machar and Melissa Chen who were just
kind of doing like IDW one on one stuff.
And you,
you asked me an interesting question during the Q and a,
so I'll let you present the question and then I want to hear your answer
actually before I repeat my answer.
So my question was essentially there are a lot of people who really don't like
the intellectual dark web.
I think it's just a bunch of cranks who are playing footsie with the alt right
and this objectionable way.
Um,
and totally dismiss the whole thing.
But then there,
there,
there are many other people who think,
well,
you know,
I,
I like,
I like half of the people in the,
in the intellectual dark web,
you know,
I don't maybe like the other half,
but I think it's,
they have a kind of nuanced take on it,
but they're really what,
where one loses them is the fact that,
you know,
you've had Stefan Molyneux,
Molly,
I dunno how to provide some new [inaudible].
Right?
So this,
this,
this character that people view as objectionable to whatever degree.
I don't know.
I don't follow him.
So I don't know whether they should or shouldn't view him that way.
But you know,
or Sam Harris has had Charles Murray on the podcast,
which you know,
many,
he just has a terrible reputation on the left,
largely undeserved or Joe Rogan had Alex Jones done.
Exactly.
We can do this ad infinitum.
And it seems like that is is the last place where people who might otherwise see
this phenomenon as good get off the ship.
Yeah.
Or I've,
I've had,
I think I've had conversations with people where that was kind of the last
trench to Diane in terms of criticizing the phenomenon.
So my question was,
what do you like,
what do you think about this,
do you think?
I mean,
this is also a criticism that Barry Weiss raised in her,
in her piece about it.
So I guess my answer to that would be,
I'm,
I mean,
well,
do you know this Guy Daryl Davis?
He,
he,
he's a,
a black guy who did a documentary,
can't remember the name of it,
where he met with the white supremacist.
He met with Ku Klux Klan members as a black person.
Yeah.
And just hung out with them,
talk to them about various issues,
became friends with them.
Right?
So imagine the psychological courage this to sit across from someone who
literally thinks you are an inferior kind of human being.
And to put that aside and just expand your circle of empathy to include them
preemptively,
incredibly inspirational.
So,
and he ends up getting over 200 Ku Klux Klan members to renounce their
membership and he keeps their robes in his closet as a kind of trophy of having
d radicalized them.
Okay.
And then he gets harshly criticized from black black lives matter for having,
having done this,
um,
which is,
which I found,
I find to be the most galling irony in the world because we're talking about a
person who has done more to reduce racism in this society than almost anyone I
could name in black lives matter,
right?
He is,
he is gone like a,
you know,
many,
many progressive activists,
they tend to go to the spaces that are actually most progressive already and try
to make them even more progressive.
So they show up on the university campuses already the most progressive places
on planet earth and then accused them of being systemically racist.
Right.
So we're talking about a guy who actually went into the trenches.
He plays the belly of the beast exactly.
And was successful in d radicalizing people from white racism.
Um,
the,
the point,
the point I'm making here is not not to compare obviously Charles Murray or
Stefan to,
to a Ku Klux Klan member.
My point is we ought to be expanding the range of people were willing to talk to
and disagree with.
And I think that in so far as you're able to challenge people or just expose,
expose people's ideas,
I think that in the long run,
as uncomfortable as it is,
an counterintuitive as it is,
tends to,
tends to be better.
So I'll just repeat it quickly,
but that in essence,
that last portion especially really was my answer.
Now first enough,
some of us Rogan me in San particularly,
we interview people.
So we can't say we're for,
you know,
plurality of ideas and we want to talk to people we disagree with and all that.
And then only talk to people we agree with.
So that means we are going to talk to some of these characters without getting
into any of the specifics of the people that I've had on the show.
Of course,
sometimes somebody you may not ask the right question here or there.
I'm not even,
I'm not even saying that that's what I did or didn't do.
But you have like,
otherwise we're not taking any risks.
And the group of people that will talk to will become infinitely smaller and
smaller and smaller.
And also we'll be sort of,
um,
we'll be hostages to people that don't like us in the first place.
And that's what I'm more concerned about.
It's like,
I don't want people who don't want any conversation to be happening at all to
have ownership over who I'm going to talk to.
Yeah.
Now,
on any specific moment,
could any of us do something a little bit differently?
Sure.
But in essence,
yeah,
you're asking about the gatekeeping that,
that Barry was talking about.
Yeah.
I don't even know that it's,
it's for to say.
And as
I said before,
you know,
we don't even have,
it's not like we're walking around with laminated cards and we'd go to a secret
meetings.
I'm right.
But I think the best sunlight is the best disinfectant.
I just,
I just fundamentally believe that.
And as far as I know,
no one was hurt by any of the interviews that I've done.
And I think I've,
I've helped a lot of people that were maybe into some of those ideas.
You know,
that was the one that people were giving me a lotta.
That's the day I said Daryl Davis phenomenon.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
nobody's lost.
I mean,
that's what I really believe.
And maybe that's a little,
um,
rose colored glasses of me.
But I believe that,
you know,
when,
when people were giving me crap for doing Alex Jones to like,
forget what he thinks about things for a moment,
clearly hundreds of thousands or millions of people are watching this.
I came on on a live show.
I said,
whatever.
I believe I didn't lie about anything.
I said the same thing as I say here.
And then I got emails from his people saying,
you know,
I never heard a decent liberal talk before.
Now I watched your interview with Bret Weinstein.
It's like,
wow,
that's pretty cool man.
So I just think perhaps we,
and I mean you and I in this case,
we just have a little bit more tolerance for,
I don't think if someone hears something it's going to immediately infect them
and then they're going to take that infection and infect other people.
But I think a lot of people operate in that prison.
I think so.
I mean,
uh,
one of the reasons I asked this question at the event is I was glad you did by
the one.
Yeah.
It's because,
for example,
Charles Murray has retweeted some of my pieces and you know,
I've,
I've gotten into exchanges with some of my critics where I've,
I've kind of talked them down off of the ledge of me being a sellout or
convinced them that I'm,
I'm operating in good faith and the trench there dying and criticizing me is,
well,
Charles Murray retweeted you and he is x,
y and Z.
Therefore,
I think a,
that's just,
that's like two layers of Ad Hominem.
Ad Hominem is attacking you instead of your belief,
but attacking someone else instead of your belief.
It's like,
that's a bit much.
It's Ad Hominem twice over.
But we seem to be in this,
in this place now where people like lists,
you know,
the SPLC is making lists of people that are bad people.
You know,
there was this alternative influencer graph that you probably saw.
They tried to link together.
I didn't even know,
probably 10 or 15 of the people on there and I don't,
you know,
and I looked at the list after where they were including me in this like crazy,
whatever it was.
White supremacists,
let's just say,
not only did I not know plenty of the people,
several of them I have muted because they hate me.
So it's like,
like you're just come together with anyone that has walked past you.
Oh,
you shook hands with that guy.
You didn't know who he was.
Too Bad.
You're,
you're screwed man.
Yeah,
that's it.
No,
I think,
I think I was telling this to you before we filmed,
but I think we live in a McCarthy era with regard to,
especially racism,
but also other,
other isms.
Um,
I mean,
I hope historians look back on it as that,
but you know,
we're getting,
we're getting people fired
for,
you know,
for saying the n word in an anti racist context.
You know,
Papa John's for example,
the CEO of that got fired for saying the end.
Yeah.
And there was no pushback on that.
The Guy said it in the car.
Excellent.
Anti Racist Razor.
Like recalling his,
the racist of his youth and the heinous things they would say.
Yeah.
Right.
And it gets fired.
A guy gets his name taken off the gym of his local hometown.
Just gets his reputation deep.
Sixed and right.
So like this is happening.
It happened a month later to to,
to this executive at Netflix who's in a,
in a meeting about offensive words in Netflix is comedy context.
So how do you have a meeting about offensive words without saying offensive
words unless you're just going to be talking like alphabet soup entire time.
So he says this fired.
So these are no,
nobody upon reflection thinks that these people are racists.
It is completely,
it is,
it is analogous to McCarthyism in that sense.
And the word racism has been denuded so fully of of its of its moral valence and
its moral charge at this point that you know,
people,
you know,
we're,
we're caring less and less about actual racism too,
is that that's a fear here.
Like once you,
once you strip this word of all of this,
all its moral charge,
then you have a boy who cried wolf scenario,
which ends up backfiring spectacularly.
And I would argue that that is happening.
We're seeing a surge on the,
on the far right as well.
Right.
So I think
that that was also my concern.
I mean,
before the election,
I did plenty of videos about you gotta stop calling Trump Hitler.
Yeah.
Because if he is not Hitler,
and for all the reasons that people don't like them,
the guy's not Hitler.
And it's like you keep doing that.
You won't even realize when the real bad guys go.
And the people that would be sympathetic to your views will no longer listen to
you.
Yeah.
Because they'll view you as the boy who cried wolf.
And Bill Mar del Mar called himself out for doing this for calling,
you know,
Bush and Romney racists or whatever it was.
Right.
He said that Romney,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
And he called himself out for being hyperbolic so that when,
when trunk Trump came along,
who actually has done clearly or has said clearly misogynous things is alleged
to have said some things that if he did say them are,
are clearly racist.
Yeah.
Um,
people don't care anymore because they've been so solid.
You know,
they've,
they've been called a racist a thousand times by the pundits at MSNBC.
And it's,
it's been true.
Maybe 10% of the times,
but not true.
Like for the,
the,
the funniest case it is to me was,
uh,
when,
when Trump called Omarosa a dog,
right?
At Wash u turn on NBC and Msnbc after this or,
or read the New York Times.
It is just obvious to those people that this is a racist slur.
He's called this black woman a dog.
This obviously racist.
And if you're defending it,
you're a racist too.
Okay.
And then you just,
if you have an internet connection,
yeah.
You look at the other people,
Trump has directly call the dog.
You find Mac Miller before he passed away,
of course you find,
um,
David Axelrod,
you find Adriana Huffington,
just,
you,
you find white person after white person that he is directly called the dog,
not said they did something like a dog,
cause he does,
he likes that construction too.
Right?
But he's called the white person after white person a dog.
There's no reason to believe that this was a racist incident.
And yet every pundit at Msnbc is saying that it is.
And anyone who likes Trump and you know,
watches Fox News,
they're getting these clips exported from MSNBC,
seeing themselves called as racist by called racist by implication or by
association.
And then seeing someone like Tucker Carlson who you know,
I have,
I have reservations about,
but seeing someone like Tucker Carlson make perfect sense about that.
Just destroy this view with simple logic and facts and imagine how,
how refreshing it is to have someone like Tucker doing that.
And obviously like you're,
you're going to get tired of being called a racist.
And when in cases when it's so obviously not true and there's just a lack of due
diligence,
there's a lack of any concern for,
for facts and for logic.
And that ends up having a very,
a bad effect on the other end because now Trump,
I mean there are some things Trump has said for which racism I think is the best
explanation.
I don't think he's a Klan member.
I think he's a very mild kind of New York racist of his era.
You know,
there their degrees of racism in other words.
But the point is,
it's like the,
the reason that Trump voters,
I think for the most part,
excuse him,
on some of the things he said is,
is not because,
not for the most part,
because of a random upsurge in racism that happened in 2016 but was it present
the past eight years?
You,
they're like,
there are counties that went for Obama twice that went for Trump.
It is,
it is.
I think it's largely because people are absolutely sick of being tarred as
racists.
Untethered to the facts of the specific cases.
Yeah.
And then now we've got just the match made in hell.
We've got a group that calls everyone racist.
The guy who you know is happy to bite them on every bit of it and use that as
fuel to get his base going.
And Yeah.
So what do you,
somehow I said we were going to shift out of race and we went right back to,
exactly.
Yeah.
All right,
we're going to try to finish up or something else.
But what do you,
what do you even consider yourself politically these days?
If I,
if I was trying to label you,
I mean I have a sense,
you know,
you're somewhere in that classical liberal situation,
but does that even matter to you?
Do you,
do you think of yourself a certain way?
I think if you can be gender fluid,
you should be able to be political fluid at this point.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
I don't know,
white
woman,
I,
I find your political views to quite appreciate
that.
I appreciate that.
Um,
no,
but I think,
I mean,
it is,
it is strange that like politics is a social construct,
political ideologies.
These are fully social constructs and it seems like we're getting more and more
rigid with the degree to which we take them seriously.
Um,
obviously one should take ideas seriously,
but I don't see anything to be gained from anchoring myself to conservatism or
liberalism or libertarianism,
even though I find wisdom in all of these three,
uh,
political ideologies.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean,
I think,
I think if,
if I can,
if I can make politically fluid of meme,
that would be,
that'd be great.
I will see what I can do.
All right.
Give me one other thing besides race,
what are you doing for fun?
These man,
I'm reading.
I'm reading a lot about,
I'm taking metaphysics,
taking philosophy of language in mind,
both of which I found fascinating.
All right.
You got a political future in front of you or,
Oh God,
no.
People often ask me that.
This law kinds me,
right?
People often ask me that.
No,
I would never go into politics.
Actually,
people assume that about me,
which I think is really interesting because I detest politics.
I hate it so much.
Um,
yeah.
No,
I don't.
I don't know.
I don't know why I give that vibe off,
but it's,
yeah.
I cannot see myself as a politician.
You're too same.
That's the problem.
It's been a pleasure,
man.
Likewise.
All right.
For more on Coleman,
follow him on Twitter at cold x,
man.
Hmm.